l'examen du projet de loi sur le Pass
vaccinal reprends à l'Assemblée
nationale examen sur fond de vive
tension après les propos polémiques
d'Emmanuel Macron sur les non vacciné
des déclarations qui ne vont pas aider
les députés de la majorité déjà sous
pression depuis le début des débats
certains font même remonter et de
menaces de mort par courrier il comprit
chez nous en Indre-et-Loire Samuel Colin
plusieurs centaines de mail reçu venu de
toute la France beaucoup reprennent les
mêmes termes et sont envoyés à des
dizaines de députés en même temps des
chaînes de message pour tenter de les
convaincre voter contre la loi
instaurant le Pass vaccinal les mots
sont forts participation à un génocide
privation de liberté violation des
engagements pris devant l'Union
européenne mais pour certains députés
cela va encore plus loin des menaces de
mort notamment contre Sabine Thillaye
général refléter par ce mail ou par tes
propos c'est qu'on reste je ne faut
qu'elle dise la part sur ma personne et
je crois qu'il faut garder une certaine
distance rapport à ça des messages
contre le mal Daniel Labaronne on reçoit
une cinquantaine par jour Fabienne
Colboc au moins 300 de l'examen du
projet de loi de partage le même constat
très peu proviennent de citoyens de leur
circonscription une dizaine à peine pour
Fabienne Colboc
de menaces manifeste j'ai reçu des mails
ou on sent une certaine colère les
personnes de toute la France m'écrives
pour me donner pour me donner leur avis
sur un texte de loi c'est tout à fait
normal après qu'ils aient des menaces là
on n'est plus dans l'exercice
démocratique à ce jour sur les 5 députés
d'Indre-et-Loire de ont déposé plainte
Sabine Thillaye donc et Philippe
chalumeau tous après tu as voté pour
l'instauration du passe vaccinale